[Música]
e
yo
una mañana de invierno en el río
cuando el sol sigue oculto este es el
momento en el que comienza el día de los
barcos
[Música]
en cuánto tiempo estuvo en esa barcaza
en la casa hasta 15 años pero tuvimos
otra 26 y otra tres años otra 27 años y
otra tres años antes vivían ambos padres
al igual que sus padres de richard y
chontales sienten pasión por su
profesión de marineros
el momento de la carga se realiza
siempre bajo la atenta mirada del
capitán
hoy colsa mañana chatarra o abono
richard acepta todos los envíos pero ha
tenido que reducir el número de
toneladas cargadas
a 250 y normalmente 500 525 pero con el
rhein a un nivel tan bajo no puede
cargar más si no nos quedaremos en
callados porque no hay suficiente agua
para la limpieza del casco chantal puede
contar con una ayuda inesperada
es un carter natural ecológico está
limpiando el de costado
hay algo de vegetación pero bueno está
llenándose visto más me gusta la vida a
bordo chantal por supuesto mira el
entorno es precioso la naturaleza de en
la pequeña mueble con árboles negros sin
sol blanco es hermoso
el ring es uno de los ejes de europa
constituye la frontera natural entre
francia y alemania- a lo largo de más de
180 kilómetros los dos países trabajan
juntos para protegerlo pero también para
controlarlo creada en 2012 las lanchas
rápidas de la brigada fluvial llevan las
banderas de ambos países
una pac
y las inspecciones se realizan en ambos
idiomas comprueban la bitácora para ver
si cumplen las condiciones de navegación
[Música]
básicamente comprobamos los documentos
relacionados con la seguridad del barco
todo lo relacionado con el chaleco
salvavidas el extintor las tripulaciones
de acuerdo todo está bien gracias los
franceses y los alemanes están ahí para
hacer cumplir la legislación europea
es estupendo que hagamos un control
conjunto en lugar de que vengan dos
policías uno detrás de otro
julissa en sí y me resulta agradable me
gusta trabajar con mis colegas franceses
a pesar del transporte de mercancías y
la industrialización el río no está tan
contaminado
hay libertad
adrián bonnart es el último pescador
profesional que sigue trabajando en el
río este invierno el nivel del agua es
particularmente bajo el agua está
tranquila es muy buena para la pesca con
red
está bien
es una red de masa grande y por eso solo
atrapa peces muy grandes
se trata de un pez que se ha reproducido
al menos cuatro o cinco veces para
garantizar la sostenibilidad de la
especie
vamos entra ahí estuvo buena la pesca sí
estuvo buena para nosotros cualquier
especie capturada es buena no estamos
obligados a clasificar y descartar el
80% de las capturas logra venderlo todo
si todo
adrián es un pescador pero también dice
ser un pescador de melodías
mi musa está ahí cerca es el río eso es
siempre lo ha hecho
yo venía al ring cuando era muy joven y
siempre me ha atraído
[Música]
e
en los 51 años que lleva recorriendo los
ríos europeos
richard el marinero ha visto como el
transporte fluvial ha sufrido una
metamorfosis con barcos cada vez más
grandes
horner land es por supuesto de rotterdam
24 horas al día arriba y abajo
estaba programado como el tren de alta
velocidad haya niebla hace años o lo que
sea sigue navegando y hace frío
en cuanto a la pareja de marinero se
está pensando en el relevo no sin cierto
recelo
llamó una persona para comprar el barco
ella ya no quiere vender lo escondió el
aviso
como creen que será su barco después
bueno espero que queden buenas manos y
lo mantengan limpio como yo lo he hecho
mantenemos y tomamos pero no podemos
quedarnos en el barco hasta los 100 años
las mujeres y los hombres van y vienen
el río sigue su curso lento y tranquilo
a través de los tiempos